In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 19th, on which we commemorate, our righteous
mother, Makrina, sister of St. Basil the Great and her four companions in the ascetic life.
The sister of St. Basil and St. Gregory of Nisa, St. Makrina, was the eldest of ten children
in this family of saints.
At the moment of her birth in the year 327, a mysterious personage appeared to her mother
three times, telling her to name the child after St. Thecla, the first woman martyr, and
a model for all Christian virgins.
She, however, kept this name secret, and the child was called after her grandmother, Makrina,
the elder, who had been a disciple of St. Gregory the Wonderworker, and had lived in the
forests of Pontus at the time of the Great Persecution.
Her mother occupied herself with instructing her not in secular culture and the frivolous
things common to people of their standing, but in all that in the inspired scriptures
was suited to her age and moral formation, especially the Book of Wisdom and the Proverbs.
The Psalms of David accompanied her in all that she did, on getting up in the morning,
beginning any work, finishing it, at the beginning and end of meals, before going to bed, and
on getting up at night to pray.
When she was twelve years old, her beauty not being able to be hidden, her father betrothed
her to a young man of good family and reputation, who had just completed his studies, and who promised
to wait until Makrina was of marriageable age.
However, he was taken by God before they were married, and this allowed the saint to realize
her secret desire to live in virginity in order to seek God.
Many suitors presented themselves, but Makrina preferred to see herself as a widow, without
even having enjoyed the joys and pleasures of conjugal life.
Through her hope of the resurrection, she reckoned that her spouse had left on a journey, setting
aside every link with the world, she lived with her mother, putting herself at her service
in all the domestic tasks, even those that were reserved for the slaves, and also helped
her in educating her brothers and sisters.
After her father's death in the year 341, she took on the management of their vast lands
in Pontus, Cappadocia, and Armenia, and by her example persuaded her mother to turn
to the good things that are incorruptible, the contemplation of God, and true philosophy.
They lived the ascetic life together, giving themselves to the reading of and meditation on
the holy scriptures, and Makrina was to all of them protectress, teacher, and model of virtues.
Once freed from the education of her children, Emilia shared out her possessions among them,
and turned the family home of Anisa into a monastery.
They made their servants, companions in Askisis, and Makrina succeeded in persuading basil
who had returned from Athens after having brilliantly completed his studies to renounce
a promising career as a rhetorician in order to embrace the evangelical life.
Beside the women's monastery, which grew with the addition of widows from noble families,
a community of men was formed, directed by Makrina's youngest brother, Peter, the future
bishop of Sebast.
St. Naukratius had withdrawn to a hermitage, later occupied by St. Basil, on the other bank
of the iris, and provided for needy old men with the spoils of his hunting.
freed from the bondage to the needs of the body, and preoccupation with this life, Makrina
and her companions led in their retreat a life on the borders of human and angelic nature.
With them there were seen neither anger, envy, hatred, or arrogance, nor anything like them.
All desire for honor or glory was banished, their pleasure was temperance, their glory to
be known to no one, their fortune to possess nothing.
They lived from the work of their hands, but remained free from preoccupation, for their
true work consisted in meditation on the divine realities, unceasing prayer, and the uninterrupted
singing of hymns.
There was, for them, no difference between night and day.
For the night found them busy with the works of light, while their day imitated the repose
of night by the absence of care in their lives.
Refined by Askecies, St. Makrina's body was as it would be at the resurrection.
She shed as many tears as the water she drank, and all her senses were consecrated to the
things of God, so that she lightly walked on the heights with the heavenly powers.
The application of true philosophy in Christ by the crucifixion of all the covetousness
of the flesh allowed her to grow incessantly, in virtue, right to the peak of perfection.
One day, a tumor attacked Makrina's breast.
Despite her mother's pleading, she refused to receive the care of a doctor, judging that
to reveal part of her body to a man's eyes would be more unpleasant than the illness.
She spent the night in prayer in the church, and anointed the wound with mud, made with
her tears.
In the morning, she asked Emilia to make the sign of the cross over her breast, and the
tumor disappeared, leaving only a tiny scar.
She had achieved such impassibility by her diligence in the things of God, that on the death
of Naukratius in a hunting accident, she was for her mother, and the rest of the family,
a model of mastery of self, and faith in eternal life.
In the successive griefs that fell on the community, she showed the same greatness of soul, steadfast
as an athlete exposed to blows, both in front of Emilia's coffin, and when St. Basil, the
son of Orthodoxy, fell asleep in the year 379.
If she then grieved, it was less at the loss of a brother than to see the church deprived
of its teacher and support.
During the famine that fell on Cappadocia in the year 368, Anisa's monastery became indeed
a city of charity, a refuge and consolation for all the local people, and by the saint's
prayers, the grain reserves which were given to all in need were miraculously replenished.
Shortly after St. Basil's death, St. Gregory of Nisa learned that his sister had fallen
gravely ill, and visited her in the monastery after nine years of absence.
She found her lying on a board, attacked by fever, but holding her spirit free in the
contemplation of heavenly blessings, so that this refreshed her body as with a dew.
When they spoke together of the great Basil, the saint, instead of grieving, used the moment
to speak at length on the nature of man, the meaning of creation, the soul and the resurrection
of the body.
On all these subjects, her discourse flowed like water from a spring, easily and unimpeded.
Until the last moment she did not stop speaking as a philosopher on that which she had made
the object of her choice, the love of the invisible spouse whom she was in haste to join, no attachment
to this life being able to hold her back.
When she felt the end approaching, she stopped speaking to those around her, and her eyes
turned to the east, stretching out her hands to God.
She murmured this prayer.
It is thou, Lord, who has banished for us the fear of death.
It is thou who has determined the length of our days here below, the beginning of true
life.
It is thou who give us to our bodies a time of rest, and who arouse us again at the sound
of the last trump.
It is thou who commitest to the earth in safe keeping, the clay that thy hands have fashioned,
to come and take that which thou has given, transforming by immortality and beauty that in
us which is mortal and defaced.
It is thou who has delivered us from accursedness and sin, having become both for our sakes.
It is thou who has broken the head of the dragon that had cast man down into the abyss of disobedience,
having seized us in its jaws.
It is thou who has opened to us the path of resurrection, having smashed the gates of hell and has
reduced to powerlessness him who reigned over the dead.
It is thou who has given to all who fear thee the sign of the Holy Cross to destroy the adversary
and give stability to our lives.
O eternal God, for whom I have been yearning from my mother's womb, thou whom my soul has
loved with all its strength, thou to whom I have consecrated my body and soul from my youth
to this moment.
Give an angel of light to stand beside me and lead me by the hand to the place of refreshment
and the waters of repose in the bosom of the Holy Father's.
Thou who didst extinguish the fire of the flaming sword and take into paradise the good thief
who was crucified with thee and who cast himself on thy mercy, remember me also in thy kingdom.
For I too was crucified with thee.
I have nailed my flesh to the fear of thee and have been seized with fear at thy precepts.
Do not separate me from thy neglect by an unbridgeable abyss.
May the envious one not stand against me on my path nor my sin be placed before thine eyes
if through the weakness of my nature I have fallen into sin in thought, word, or deed.
Thou who hast hear on earth the power to remit sins, remit mine so that I may take breath
and that once separated from this body I may appear before thee with an irreproachable
and immaculate soul as incense before thy face.
With these words the saint traced the sign of the cross on her eyes, mouth and heart.
She was silently present at the evening office and then with a great sigh her prayer and
her life together ended.
During her funeral over which Saint Gregory presided and at which a huge crowd was present
Saint Macrinas' spiritual beauty shown in a striking way on her body which had been clothed
as a bride, accompanied by the singing of hymns as on the feasts of the martyrs, she was
buried at Ibona in the same tomb as her parents in the church of the 40 martyrs.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God have mercy on us
and save us.